these players were supposed to be the
underdogs but they were superior in
every way
the famous old trophy is heading back to
west london for a second time
nine years after the first their manager
thomas tuckel
a former barman serving up a tactical
master class
and celebrating with his young family
chelsea made the crucial breakthrough
just before half time
an inch perfect pass from mason mount a
moment of composure from kai habits
and then the easy bit chelsea's most
expensive player
repaying some of his 75 million pound
transfer fee
and a nervous moment for pep guardiola
man city are owned by a shake and
chelsea an oligarch
but in this battle of the billionaires
first blood went to roman abramovich
a final throw of the dice for city as
their greatest goalscorer sergio aguero
came on
but this was a night when none of their
stars shun
this was the biggest mass departure from
the uk since before the start of the
pandemic
fourteen thousand one hundred and ten
were inside porto's stadio dodragao
and it was chelsea fans celebrating at
the end
chelsea were underdogs going into this
match but you leave as european champion
you prefer being out under dogs every
time we play underdogs we always
come out on top just the atmosphere was
incredible
16 000. the singing that does it yeah
but they played brilliantly it was
sensational it was a great day
it was absolutely brilliant today to be
in the stadium football is back
and to experience a nightlight tonight
absolutely ecstatic
unforgettable some manchester city fans
regretting the journey says it was
bobbins today
bobbins i'm upset
that he didn't play a striker pep
guardiola is the ultimate obsessive
tactician
but perhaps on the biggest stage of all
he was guilty of
overthinking how he set up his team and
manchester city paid for it
the quest for a first champions league
title for manchester city continues
for chelsea it was a historic win in
porto
celebrated just as fulsomely 1 600 miles
away
in london martha kellner sky news porto